Like all comic book universes, DC Comics is
made up of a sprawling canon of fan-favorites
and total busts.
On one hand, you've got your holy trinity
of Superman, Batman, and Wonder Woman.
On the other hand, you've got the likes of
Pandora, Azrael, or Jason Todd as Robin.
Everyone has their favorites, their worsts
and firsts but what about lifelong comics
fan and comic actor Jason Mewes?
We had the opportunity to speak with Mewes
aka Jay, of Jay and Silent Bob fame while
he was promoting his film Madness in the Method,
which he stars in and directed as his debut
feature behind the camera.
Knowing that he knows his stuff when it comes
to comic books, we asked him for his take
on the three best and three worst characters
DC Comics has to offer.
"If we're going powerhouses, I have my favorites,
but again I wouldn't say they're the strongest.
But I would have to say for a team I would
say Batman, Superman, and Martian Manhunter.
Because Martian Manhunter, to me, has just
as much power and such as Superman.
He does have weaknesses.
But he can turn intangible and invisible and
such.
Mewes was clear that with his selection of
favorites, he mostly went for raw strength
over scrappy personality, and that he might
personally prefer some characters who don't
hit quite so hard.
"I love Deadshot too as a character.
Deadshot's one of my favorite characters.
And yeah, and Vigilante, but they're not very,
you know…"
After selecting his top three, Mewes had a
surprising amount of trouble getting into
the DC Comics characters he likes least.
In general, the real-life Jay doesn't seem
to dislike much of anything.
When it comes to fandom, he's like a living
embodiment of that one song from The LEGO
Movie.
"I would say worse characters...
I mean I don't think there is worse characters.
I mean again it’s… they're all sort of
awesome."
But then, in a eureka moment, he started seeing
double, and found two of his worsts in one
shot.
"The freaking Wonder Twins.
I mean I know they can turn into most things,
but in the cartoon, they only turn into like
water and ice and hawks and stuff.
I'm sure they could turn maybe into like dragons
and maybe something cooler, but maybe not.
So those two are the worst off the top of
my head."
"You were terrific, Zan.
First a wave, now a drip."
So that's two.
Sorry, Zan and Jayna, but when it comes to
superhero tier lists, apparently you're down
there with the likes of King Tut.
"Another worst, I would say, I don't know
why, I'm not a fan of if we're going old school,
King Tut, or like I'm not a fan of the Penguin.
I know he was sort of cool, but not really."
In selecting his three worst DC characters,
Mewes spent a lot of time expounding on the
comic book brand's villains, which he says
include some of his favorite comic book characters
in general.
Of particular note for him outside of his
top three is the whole collection of Batman's
rogues' gallery, including Two-Face, The Riddler,
and all the other fiends and foes who tend
to cross paths with justice in Gotham City.
It's not just what they do in comics, cartoons,
and on film that makes them neat to him.
It's also all the toy sets they end up in,
which he has a habit of collecting.
"I would say, I mean the Rogues from DC and
Batman.
I mean I love all the sets they have of, again
going from me from collecting toys, like the
Rogues Gallery and stuff, like Clay Face,
and Joker, Poison Ivy, all that stuff are
pretty awesome.
And then I love Suicide Squad from the comics.
You know, so Harley Quinn is pretty cool,
and Joker, and Deadshot's on that team.
Not the Fresh Prince of Bel-Air's Deadshot."
"Y'all jokers must be crazy."
Outside of his top and bottom three, it's
clear Mewes knows a thing or two about DC
Comics characters, probably as much, if not
more, than the actors who actually play them
in adapted form on screen.
He's an actor, so it begs the question would
he ever want to suit up to play a DC Comics
hero or villain himself?
"And I would say no, because I love.
Like I'm not saying I would turn them down
But I don't think I'd want to play a character
because I love watching the movies, the TV
shows so much."
On top of checking out Jason Mewes' directorial
debut Madness in the Method, out now via video
on demand, you can also see him in the upcoming
View Askewniverse sequel Jay and Silent Bob
Reboot, touring the United States in a roadshow
format starting October 15.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
comic book characters are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.